if you want to understand modern
American society the first thing you
need to realize is that lots of people
are very unhappy and those unhappy
people tend to think that their
unhappiness can be cured by majority
vote essentially if they can convince
other people to live the way that they
live and do the things that they do and
become as as unhappy as they are then
magically it will have the effect of
making them happy and in a similar way
they believe that if they can convince
everyone else that they are not unhappy
even though they are indeed deeply and
tragically unhappy then they will become
happy and if none of those strategies
work of course which they don't then
there's always antidepressants which
also don't work
what I've just described could of course
be summarized by the cliche misery loves
company and that as it happens would
also be a great title for Chelsea
Handler's autobiography if she ever
writes one not that the title of the
book that nobody will read really
matters Chelsea Handler of course is a
comedian at least I've gathered based on
context clues that she's a comedian or
trying to be one anyway never actually
heard her tell anything that can be
immediately recognized as a joke that is
unless we step back and view her career
through a wider lens and see that her
entire career is the joke maybe this is
some sort of like performance art that
she's doing
and if that's what she's going for then
she is pulling it off uh and masterfully
so I have to say now recently Handler
took uh the job of guest host on The
Daily Show after Trevor Noah's departure
and we can't be sure what the producers
had in mind when they hired a shrill
unfunny spinster with all the wit and
charm of a bitter middle-aged woman
standing in line at Target while loudly
complaining that they don't have enough
registers open I can only assume that
there are maybe some Trevor Noah
loyalists still on the staff who wanted
to find someone who could manage to make
him seem funny in retrospect maybe
that's what's going on whatever the
thought process it didn't take Handler
very long to steer the show in the only
Direction she knows how to go which is
desperately justifying her own life
choices
especially her choice to not have
children
and actually I need to amend that
slightly because it's not that Handler
has chosen not to have children it's
that she's chosen not to allow any of
her children to live
she is childless today thanks to the
three abortions that she often brags
about she doesn't have any living
children we should say she is however
the mother of three dead children babies
who are sacrificed on the altar of her
quote-unquote Freedom a freedom that was
purchased with the blood of her own
children
just to clarify that's what we're
talking about
recently as many people have seen in
viral clips of the show Handler
dedicated an episode to defending and
promoting her child-free lifestyle
now normally nothing involving Chelsea
Handler or The Daily Show for that
matter is worth talking about
but in this case she inadvertently
raises I think a few points few
important points that are worth
discussing so I think it's it's worth
spending a little bit of time on this so
here's Chelsea
one thing that I have made abundantly
clear is that I do not want children I
say it on stage
I say it in interviews it's the first
thing I say to myself in the mirror when
I wake up each morning right before I
tell myself God you're a dynamic woman
[Applause]
kids don't respect me and quite frankly
the feeling is mutual
and the fact is there are millions of
women just like me but for some reason
every single one of us at some point in
our lives is shamed by Society for not
wanting a baby and that's what I want to
talk about in tonight's installment of
long story short
well actually Chelsea Society wouldn't
know or especially care that you don't
have kids nobody's running up to you on
the street screaming hey where are your
babies you better have babies
rather you know you often talk about
your decision to be childless and you
talk about it in the most obnoxious ways
you possibly can which gives everyone
else in society the right to give their
own opinion about your choices and the
reasoning behind those choices
this is the way it works and something
that everyone needs to understand
because a lot of people struggle with
this you see when you present your
lifestyle choice to the public
when you go on TV and talk about it in
front of millions of people or at least
hundreds of people in the case of The
Daily Show you have submitted that
lifestyle choice for public discussion
you cannot go to the public and say hey
guess what here's a fact about me and
the way that I live my life you can't do
that and then get offended when people
say well here's my opinion about that
you gave that information to us people
naturally form opinions about the
information you tell them now nobody has
the right to go banging on your front
door and demanding to know how many kids
you have but everyone has the right to
form opinions about the unsolicited
information you give them don't want
their opinion well then don't tell them
about it
now let's listen to her continue to tell
us about it
in America and honestly everywhere
motherhood is treated as a woman's
Central purpose in life as if our
destiny is to let a tiny stranger rip a
hole through our Pikachu from the inside
out and then as soon as we turn 18 we're
just supposed to sit back and wait for
Nick Cannon to impregnate us
yeah you see it's funny because she made
a reference to pop culture we all know
that a statement is automatically
hilarious when it refers to Something in
pop culture that we all recognize you
don't need to have an actual punch line
no joke is needed simply say hey you
guys remember this thing from pop
culture and then wait for the uproarious
laughter to commence especially if
you're in front of the studio audience
where they're instructed to laugh and it
really works
next we hear testimonials from other
childless women who have been viciously
discriminated against by Society they
claim and the Ode to childlessness goes
on for for a while longer and it leads
eventually to this
right about 1
once your grand fee the other day
realistic huh miserable I am I'm
miserable on the beach
and then here I am miserable on the top
of a mountain
and then here I am miserable scuba
diving
and then I'm miserable again smoking a
joint in a hot tub
hey it's truly a new circle of hell for
me
the simple truth is that I'm not having
a kid because I'm happier without them
and that's really not of anyone's
concern but my own
and no I don't hate kids I just don't
want them that's what's so great about
nieces and nephews I love being an aunt
I'm crushing that role guess who gave
each one of them their first edible this
girl
[Applause]
hey see Chelsea you're 47
years old so giving drugs to kids
doesn't make you a cool ant it makes you
a creep and worse time to start planning
for your retirement is now the U.S blew
through 31.4 trillion dollars in debt uh
in December and still the White House
refuses to reduce spending with the
troubling state of the United States
economy it's time to start thinking
about how you invest and what your
Investments are what your future is
going to be you need to consider
diversifying into gold with Birch gold
since 2003 Birch gold has become a
leading dealer of physical precious
metals in the U.S today with a dynamic
team of former wealth managers financial
advisors and commodity Brokers they
continue to help customers diversify
their portfolios with gold silver
platinum and Palladium whatever that is
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metals with your retirement at stake you
want to be confident in the financial
service companies that you work with
including who you choose for purchasing
physical precious metals so just text
Walsh to 989898 to claim your free info
kit on gold and then talk to one of
their precious metal Specialists virtual
will help will hold your hand through
the entire process text Walsh to 989898
to protect yourself with gold today with
an A plus uh a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help
protect my savings and to protect yours
as well text Walsh to
989898 today
also if your decision to not have any
living children is not anyone's concern
but your own then why did you dedicate a
10-minute segment on national TV to it
once again that's the question
well you did it as we established at the
beginning partly because you're trying
to convince yourself of your own
happiness this partly explains virtually
everything that any leftist says about
almost any subject
it's it's it's almost always at least in
part a game of them convincing
themselves that they're happy with the
way they've chosen to live their lives
and also you did it because you wish to
promote
your empty miserable lifestyle in the
hopes that more people will join you in
it
and it's for that latter reason that I
feel compelled to make two points in
response
first
I must again point out
that you're 47 years old nothing wrong
with being 47
the point is that you could have had
kids and yet still be at this point
climbing all the mountains and hanging
out on all the beaches that you want
because children don't stay toddlers
forever they grow up
okay if you had a child at the age when
the average woman in America has
children these days even though I mean
that average age is is going up and and
it's getting older and older but even
now after after that process has
happened uh your child would be about 21
years old right now if you follow the
sort of the average trajectory
and if your child followed the average
trajectory by the time you're in your
early 50s your child would be married
with a child of Their Own the point is
that at your age you could have all of
your precious freedoms all of your
vacations all the time in the hot tub
that you want all the time to to sleep
in that you want especially if you don't
have a job and also a family
see you're too old now to use this
argument that you want to make
to use the argument of like you see you
see how easy my life is I don't have to
get up in the morning with a screaming
baby that might work when you're still
not a compelling argument but like at
least it's relevant when you're 28
because if you were 28 and you had a kid
there's a very good chance a kid would
be a baby you can't do that when you're
47. there are very few 47 year olds even
ones with uh with with lots of kids that
are waking up in the middle night with a
baby
you know it's like going up to somebody
who just finished a marathon and
bragging that you get to sit down and
relax and you don't have to run a
marathon well the person who just
finished it also can sit down and relax
yet they get to do it with the knowledge
that they finished a marathon so you're
both relaxing now but only one of you
ran a marathon
who's in the better spot indeed who can
who can enjoy that relaxation more
see that's a factor that isn't often
taken into consideration but it's an
important life lesson
as a childless person
um you don't get to experience the joys
of having children obviously
but you also don't really get to
experience the benefits of not having
children
you don't actually experience that
or I should say you might experience
them but you don't appreciate them you
can't
you see you've always been able to sleep
in you've never had to wake up in the
middle of the night with a crying baby
uh you've always been able to sit in the
hot tub whenever you want you've always
been able to take vacations wherever and
whenever you want you've never known
what it's like to not have any of that
which means you can't experience all of
the joy of having it
the only people who can truly enjoy not
running a marathon are those who've run
marathons it only makes sense for
someone who's run marathons to wake up
in the morning and say man I'm glad I'm
not running a marathon today
for all the rest of us that's just that
we've never experienced it before so
every day is not running a marathon so
we never really have that moment of buff
thank God I'm not running a marathon
this is the Catch-22 of Life only the
people who've done something can enjoy
not doing that same thing
so older people who've raised young
children and have now moved past that
phase of Life certainly do feel relief
that they no longer have to deal with
some of the challenges that come with
that phase they also look back and and
miss a lot of that okay you talk to any
47 year old who's had kids and they've
moved past it you're going to hear them
say a lot about how I miss those days
man I really miss those days but they're
also parts of those days that they don't
miss they don't they don't miss having
to wake up in the middle of the night or
wake up early in the morning with it
with a kid they don't miss that
they're relieved to be past that
but you don't have that relief because
you never were in that phase you didn't
earn the relief they did so they feel it
in a way that you never will
then again I should also note that even
parents of young children can sit can
still sit in hot tubs and go to go to
the beach and enjoy uh and even climb
mountains if they want it may take more
planning it may involve complications
that you don't have to deal with uh if
you don't have kids but despite popular
misconceptions you don't have to put
your life on hold when you have kids you
don't have to give up really any of the
things you like to do or any of your
passions
I mean provided that they're uh you know
they're they're fruitful and and good
things
instead you learn to be intentional with
your time you learn to make good use of
the time that you have and that's a
skill that you Chelsea would have done
well to acquire but you clearly never
did second
and finally
having children and this is maybe the
most important point
having children will not automatically
make anyone happy that's true okay
nobody is claiming that if you have a
baby you will immediately become
unspeakably happy and you'll remain that
happy forever experiencing an unbroken
chain of pure uncomplicated Joy until
the day you die that is not the case and
nobody has ever said that it's the case
in fact if you're determined to be
miserable as a parent
there will be many opportunities
presented to you to be as miserable as
you want to be
no the point is that parenting opens up
the possibility for Joy unique kinds of
joy that are simply not available and
are indeed in some ways inconceivable to
non-parents
so the happiness that you're talking
about Chelsea vacations and hot tubs and
so on
these are self-centered things you're
happy because of the comfort and
entertainment that's being provided to
you
there's nothing wrong with that in
moderation everyone is familiar with
that kind of happiness
and it's available to everyone parents
and non-parents alike
but the joy of parenting in a family
life
is a joy found in caring for someone
else
and that is a joy that you Chelsea have
never in your life experienced ever
you you can't conceive of it you don't
know what it is you have lived your
whole life
without it and will die without it and
will be worse for it
this is the joy in giving in loving it's
the joy found in the bond that holds
families together it's a simple joy and
it's free
and it's more pure and more beautiful
than any joy that can be provided to you
by a vacation resort
it's a joy that if you open yourself to
it
makes you a better person it makes you
less selfish less superficial less
focused on your own needs and wants in
other words
a parent who opens themselves up to the
joy of Parenthood will become well a lot
less like Chelsea Handler
and that is perhaps the best
advertisement for parenting that I can
offer
offer that'll do it for this portion of
the shows and move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]